Conor,
>> do you think it's prudent to send
homemade to somebody when you've only
known them for 10 days? Yes or no?
You're so full of
>> it's mindblowing.
>> Conor, I have
just watch your content for the last 6
months and see you running away from
your own talking points. How many
friends do you have left, by the way? At
what point do you go, "Oh, it's me."
>> But you are such a that it is impossible
to be your friend. It's impossible to be
your partner. It is impossible to tell
you that you're wrong. It's impossible
for you to take a L.
So, if you guys missed it, Counter
Points had a stream today and he was
talking to Doobie and then I think
eventually Destiny hops on and dude, it
goes it goes pretty crazy. There's a lot
of fighting back and forth and Dubie
will make a point of okay well when Desi
dox his people he's putting people's
family at risks and he's like creating
what we would call a permission
structure or a a possible lens by which
people will judge him and act against
him right that while we principally
don't
is sort of losing his moral high ground
to say people should defend me against
these these kinds of actions right but I
I think that this situation is actually
quite serious and you are thinking about
like complete disassociation for me and
wick so this is not a serious
conversation I'm I won't understand.
I'll just hang out. I'm sorry. I'm being
honest. Like that's that opinion is so
immediately stupid. I'm not even going
to pretend to have a conversation with
you.
>> Is I'm not going to have you say that
after you and I have had a five going on
six-year relationship that you get to
deem a topic undeserving of your time,
attention, or conversation. That's not
happening. WELL, THEY THINK THAT YOU USE
YOUR SEXUAL POWER and clout and
influence and money in order to mentally
women.
>> Give me what example. Annavore. You're
saying that he's creating the stochastic
permission structure through which you
can be ducks and harassed. And since
you're being ducks and harassed, you
have the right to dox him. So So hold
on. You think Jtock, Queman, esports
Batman, they all hate you for delusional
or non-serious reasons?
>> Yes.
>> Uh I Okay,
>> that's crazy.
>> Okay, dude.
>> Hey, so uh going back to the food traps
thing, do you guys want to explain why
you guys don't like each other or what's
the
>> Yeah, off to kids. That's gross.
Shouldn't off to kids.
>> The silence is
>> dep.
>> Let's even pretend that
>> notice how you didn't deny that you jerk
off to kids. So, why don't we just go
ahead and answer this question right
now? You jerk off to kids.
>> No.
>> Okay. Do you jerk off to cartoon
drawings of kids?
>> Yeah.
>> There you go. But but notice but notice
>> wasn't Wasn't your advice from everybody
to not say that anymore? That was
literally the advice everybody IS GIVING
YOU. STOP SAYING THAT. STOP DOUBLING
DOWN on that. Stop. Stop. You got to
stop. YOU GOT TO STOP. YOU GOT TO STOP
doing it.
>> Notice how But notice how you go after
me for
>> depictions. Stop off the cartoon kids. I
let you finish. I let you finish.
>> I don't care if you let me finish. Stop
off the cartoon kids. It's gross.
>> Okay, then stop depending. Stop off the
cartoon kids. It's [__]
>> By the way, I don't think Connor defends
me.
>> Gross.
>> That's such a Wait, you guys are
bringing up like the most difficult
>> You really got me. You really got me.
>> I did. You dropped the cartoon kids.
It's gross. Stop doing it.
>> I'm going to repeat this next 30 minutes
whenever. You two cartoon children. Stop
to cartoon children.
>> Are you going to agree to stop cartoon
children?
Food chops.
>> Is that going to be an actual
conversation? Like a
>> No, it's not. I'm I'm going to ask you a
very simple question, which is, are you
going to commit to no longer to cartoon
children?
>> Dude, Destiny's strongest soldier has
one kryptonite and it's Could you stop
off the kids and then deathly silent
after that me? That's crazy.
>> Just say yes. We can move on.
>> Why the Yeah, I'm totally going to stop.
Okay.
>> Okay. That's
>> Yeah, I'm like totally going to stop.
>> Sounds like sarcasm, so I don't believe
you. And they just said just say yes.
So, I don't believe you. Instead of
>> No, no, no. He's right. Instead of to
cartoon kids, um, I'll just think of you
instead. Okay.
>> Don't do it.
>> You'll just do what?
>> I'll just think of you instead.
>> Is wait. Someone said
>> it. He Trust me, Connor is going to
think that's much better, right?
Connor's just going to go, "Oh, thank
you. I'm an adult." That's like weird,
but at least, you know, it's better than
the kid thing. Thank you.
>> Wick is here. Oh, wow. I'm here.
>> Okay. So, can we move on from the free
conversation? It sounds like we're like
stuck at a dead end. Like, wait, do you
have any He doesn't He's too cowardly.
He's too cowardly to actually have a
conversation or a debate. It's fine.
>> Sorry. What What do you want to talk
about besides the fact that you off to
Cartoon Kids?
>> No, I'm just saying you're a total
hypocrite. He is the one comparing to
actual is so crazy. That's so insane.
But yeah, go ahead.
>> You moral kids, you freak. I don't even
know why they tolerate you guys just
loop on this over and over and over
again
about
>> I think I wanted to just if I may if I
may like
>> counter points um Connor
>> what
>> buddy I understand that you feel
>> he's afraid he's 100% afraid
>> no I felt this way for a year
>> I know I get it
>> I felt this way the entire time I think
you're disgusting and the fact that you
don't you haven't changed your mind and
whenever somebody brings up the fact
that you off the cartoon kids you just
go oh I said that a long time you think
people don't notice you think people
don't notice that you don't rebut the
fact that you still engage with but you
said oh I said this a long time you
think people don't notice that you're a
pedo
>> no I know I'll think of you instead I'll
think of you instead I'll think of you
instead okay it's okay
>> that would well I'm an adult man so that
would a step in the right direction.
>> Hell yeah. See, that's what I'm talking
about. See, done. Topic done, right? You
won't bring this up again in the future.
>> No, I will bring every I'm going to
bring this up.
>> But I'll I'll talk to you instead. Okay,
it's okay.
>> That is a upgrade.
>> That's better.
>> See, that's not a kid.
>> That's an agreement right there.
>> Yes, you talk to adults if you're an
adult.
>> Wait, let's let's let's let Wick speak.
Let's let Wick speak. Quick, speak your
mind.
>> I get it, Connor. I do. I think
yesterday went yesterday didn't have to
go how it did. There was a path and I
think that there was a way for everyone
to win. But
and I get why. I think that you you let
kind of your stubbornness
uh your just you your feeling of being
attacked and under pressure.
>> Dude, what the gaslighting is crazy.
Okay. get you to make decisions that I
think that
>> Totally not a cult, by the way. Just not
cultlike whatsoever. Not a cult. Not a
cult, guys, at all.
>> You You didn't have to make I
>> Yeah, he was crashing out.
>> Well, well, hold on. I I want to be fair
to counterpoints because I I do
sympathize, right? Like, and I I talked
to you before everything happened, like
the first time I hopped on and and I I
thought it went well. Like, hey, I get
it. You don't want to compromise your
principles. Um, fair enough. Uh but
look, there is a mass amounts of people
attacking someone that you consider a
friend, coming at them like way beyond
just like uh um making fun of him or
critical of his takes and things like
literally trying to ruin his life. So he
asked you a favor, right? He asked you a
favor like, "Hey,
>> I don't want these people in communities
connected to me." Now I get it. Wait,
but Wick, you literally said no to this.
Wick, you literally said no to this.
>> You don't want to ban anyone for that.
And you know what? I was able to talk to
him the day before and get a compromise
as well. Like, hey, I want to ban people
that uh just for for saying things,
right? Like, I don't want to ban that,
but I was and he was very reasonable
with me. Like, so I don't I don't know
why you guys didn't go that route. Like,
why not? What happened?
>> Because I'm not going to accept the
implicit threat of what's being said.
>> It's not an implicit threat. Someone's
asking me for a favor. You that you know
full goddamn well as much as I do. Moot
so much has confirmed it that the simple
ask of don't allow snarkers in your
community in order to endlessly talk me
that never happened in my community.
There's no evidence that it ever
happened in my community. They're making
a [__] up whole cloth. And so the
implication is kick these two people
from your community or else we don't
hang out anymore. I've been hanging out
with Stephen for six goddamn years. I
deserve more than that. And if he
doesn't like it then he off.
>> Sorry. What was funny?
>> Ignore food chopped. Ignore food. What
was what was funny? The person who off
the cartoon kids who shouldn't have a
career at all. You're going to get
you're going to start losing on this.
Look, again, there were paths where you
didn't have to kick anyone out. I
understand that it was um that you feel
that it was a and I I don't hang out in
the cog, so I can't speak either way to
whether it's true or not, right? It
doesn't matter. Um, but there were like
even giving him the chance to kind of
come in, check every once in a while,
see what's going on.
>> He's not the police.
>> He's your friend, bro.
>> Yeah. And my friend should have the
balls to allow people to talk about him
on the internet. Or if he's going to
say, "These people are engaged in a life
ruination campaign against me." Then
they should be able to produce evidence.
>> And if they don't produce evidence, I'm
going to tell them. I'm telling you, you
think yesterday was bad.
>> The evidence is TDD, by the way. Like a
like a phrase that has been used on the
internet forever.
>> I'm tired now. I just talked to the
snarkers for 6 hours. It's going to be
bad tonight. Okay. Because I'm not going
to have this is very
>> go, oh, these two people are bad. Remove
them from your community. Okay. Can you
produce evidence that these two people
are bad? Nope. You just have to trust
me. You
>> did produce evidence. You may not have
found it sufficient, but that evidence
exists. I can confirm some of it exists.
>> So, so do you or not?
>> Do you?
>> Again, these people are all connected.
It's like structure like in Isis the uh
the people in that destiny. Dude, how
did Wick how did Wick go from like
apparently a neutral actor to totally
like at the the tail end of the most
cultish in like two seconds? I was a
neutral actor. These people are all
connected. They're like ISIS. THEY'RE
LIKE SPLIT. THEY'VE SPLIT THEELVES.
>> Do the bombing. But they
>> The reason why I'm ask Oh, so you you
have you have like a videotaped sermon
>> of death of Dubbie being an ISIS
proitizer.
>> So go ahead. Please give me that.
>> He's like a propagandist, dude.
>> Yeah. You just said that he's a
propaganda. So do you have you have the
video or extended text messages of the
propagandist?
>> You mean you having you having Dubie on
the entire time? We don't even need to
look at like Dubie in the voice chat.
Like why do we even need to look at
that? You're the one who had him on.
>> What did Dub say that you think is
incorrect?
>> The way that he kind of moral frogs
about Steven mind literally every single
woman that comes this way. What are you
talking about? Like to do it.
>> I've said like multiple times. I don't
think I think he's too mentally ill to
use the oh he just targets mentally ill
people. I've like totally changed my my
thoughts on that.
>> I used to lean into that meme. It's not
that's not what it is. M.
>> Does Steven not mentally ill women
routinely?
>> Wait. Let's run this right way too long.
What's our strongest example of this?
>> Strongest example.
>> Yeah.
>> How about Brit?
>> I've never met this person in real life
in my entire life.
>> Yeah. Are you can with them right now?
>> They try to add me on 50 million
accounts right now. No, I'm not.
>> Yeah, I know you are.
>> Okay. I'm literally not
right now. I bet they saying please add
me again.
>> Wait, who's Brit?
>> I [__] What's the strongest go-to
example of mentally ill women?
>> Okay,
hold on.
Uh, it's it's just crazy. There's no way
this just said Brit. I'm sorry. I gotta
I don't know who that is exactly.
Southern.
>> Oh, Southern. Let's assume that I
shouldn't have seen her the third time.
Okay.
>> No, I don't care about you seeing these
people. Off. H. Sorry, but that's fine.
>> Even if JTO's worse than you. Let's say
Jtock's a What does that have to do with
you?
Yeah, just give that away. Please just
give away that I'm Connor in the future.
Just say, "Yeah, he's actual."
>> That's what you want. J's
>> Okay, you
>> That's fine. As long as you acknowledge
J's, that's fine.
>> Thank you. Yes. Let's go. I'll just say
it's very obvious that Destiny is
incredibly mentally ill. He is the last
person who should ever be stigmatizing
other people's mental illness. The his
treatment.
>> Okay. When you meet Brett, you want to
play this game? Let's play this game.
When did you meet Brit?
>> I've never met this person in real life
before.
>> Okay. When did you meet her digitally?
>> I don't remember. I'm not going to dig
through here and have you audit the
lives of people who DM me crazy on
Discord, though. This is not relevant to
the conversation. And this is a new
person.
>> It is relevant to the conversation,
isn't it?
>> This is a new
>> Wow, this is crazy.
>> New person that you want to attack me
with, Conor, but it has nothing to do
with the reason why you've obsessed over
my life for the past like years. Ah,
let's go.
>> At least.
>> Do you know why?
>> Because you are reaping what you've
seown. You are reaping what you've seown
and you haven't learned your lesson. And
it sucks.
>> Okay. In my current court case drama,
who what is the what what is the sewn
part? What did I sew here? Or was it
immoral?
>> Was it immoral for you to have sex with
Pixie? It was immoral for you to take
her homemade and send it to somebody
that you'd only known for 10 days.
>> Okay. So, obviously for us, so it was
immoral for us to record something or it
was immoral for us to trade it or
>> it's immoral for you to trust somebody
you've never met after 10 days with
homemade of your friends.
>> Let's assume that's the case. Let's
assume that that's true to anybody with
a brain.
>> Conor, then why is Pixie okay to share
with a woman she's never even met in her
life?
>> Destiny, when I'm I'm not talking about
everybody else. I'm talking about me and
>> I'm talking about you,
>> Connor. If me and Okay, hold on. Do you
think that Pixie des
>> he's going to do the thing where he
compares like Pixie, sorry, Molina, who
is Destiny's wife, long-term partner,
who's supposedly trustworthy, right, to
a sex worker he'd known for 10 days and
met on Twitter.
>> Did she reap what she sowed? Yes, she's
a dumb. She shouldn't have shot homemade
with you.
>> Does every single person who shoots
homemade have it leaked? Are they all
reaping what they've seown?
>> Destiny, how about this question? Do you
think it's smart to send homemade to
somebody you've only known for 10 days?
>> I don't know. Ask anybody.
>> No. No. No. No. Answer that question.
>> I don't know. I don't know what that
could it could go anyway. IT'S DUDE,
IT'S 50/50.
>> Do you think it's prudent? Do you think
it's prudent to send homemade to
somebody when you've only known them for
10 days? Yes or no? Sure, Connor. That
was the behavior that everybody
>> But you're saying yes, it is prudent.
>> Conor, why does this matter?
>> Why does this matter? Because this has
torched endless professional
opportunities for his.
That's why that's needed recommendations
from you. You I think I want
professionally. I don't need
recommendations from you. How to run my
life. Number one. Number two.
>> Yes, you do. You dumb. Because you keep
burning your own life.
>> Number two, I'm not the one.
>> You need a [__] social worker.
>> Holy [__] You're so ass pain over your
obsession with my life.
>> No, I'm not. You Okay, fine. Shut up.
Shut up. I'll just say it. I'll just say
it. After you leaked homemade, after the
entire internet hated you, you started
with another woman on Discord and you
did age play with this and she was
married to someone else and she was
married TO A GROPER. SHE WAS MARRIED TO
A GROPER.
>> SHE WAS MARRIED TO A GROPER.
>> Do you think it is prudent to
>> text message somebody who's married to a
groper? Are these are these new age play
allegations? WOULD THESE BE NEW AGE PLAY
ALIG? OH MY GOD. CONNOR DIVORCED.
>> Do I need to pass through every single
person that messages me with a nude or
wants to say? Is that what I need to do?
Do I need to get permission from you
from now on? Are you going to tell me
how to run my personal life?
>> No. But if anybody was your friend, they
would call you an idiot to your face,
which is what I'm doing right now. You
are an idiot. You are dumb. You ruin
your own life.
>> Okay. All right. Does any of this I
don't know what the point if the point
here is for Connor to go, I don't like
the way that you have sex with people or
whatever. I don't know what the the
point is of this conversation. That's
it. Okay. Yeah, fine. I'll ask you this
question. I'll make the point in
abundantly clear. When you're being sued
for leaking homemade, should you start
text messaging a woman who's married to
a political opposition that hates your
guts
>> at this point?
>> Is that saying your normal behavior?
>> The world hates my guts, Conor. But what
I do with my Okay, so the whole world
>> that's going to be So why are you saying
these people are responsible for your
guts? How do you know it's Doobie
swatting you?
>> What I do, Connor? What I do? I've never
himself swatted me like he's How do you
do the Snarkers? Because these guys
literally have the slogan at the
beginning of their [__] husband. The
husband was in a telegram channel where
gropers were plotting your murder. If
they were plotting your then don't you
think they might swat you?
>> I don't know.
>> Oh god. So many things coming together.
You're so full of
>> You are so full of
>> You want to blame exclusively Queen J
all of these people for why your life is
up and yet you ALWAYS POKE THE always
crazy. YOU IT'S EVERYBODY ELSE'S FAULT.
EVERYBODY ELSE'S FAULT. It's never
Destiny's fault. It's never Steven's
fault. We can't do a moral inventory
about what the you're doing every single
goddamn day.
>> Conor Conor is he got swapped. Conor, I
No. No. Yes. Yes, it is. I want I want
you to just say that because I people or
a lot of people, it is absolutely
everything that's happened is my fault
because of that.
>> Yeah. When you try to a married woman of
your political opposition that wants to
murder you and then you try to blame
people who hate you on the internet for
trying to swat you, but then there's
other people want to murder you because
it's criticism. I'm going to say you're
full of
>> Yeah. Thanks for the 10. Let's go.
>> So your your contention is that this
group of people I guess are they're the
ones swatting me. I didn't get
>> I have more evidence that they're
swatting them swatting you than you have
presented that the snarkers are swatting
you.
>> Connor, you have no evidence they've
swatted me.
>> Yeah, you're right. And yet I still have
more than you.
>> And yet I still have more than you.
>> Evidence
>> direct evidence or conflating direct
evidence with any evidence at all. Like
obviously this is what he does in his
own court case with regards to the Abby
testimony pretends that's not evidence
at all.
>> What's the evidence that I have? I have
the evidence that he's in a telegram
channel plotting Steven's murder. BUT
YOU WANT to take all the negativity
that's on the internet about you and you
want to sign it to one community.
>> Hunter, you're full of
>> You're full of
>> Hunter. This Telegram group appeared
like a year after my first swatting
incident. I don't know why you're
pretending that everything came from
this.
>> Your first swatting incident that was
the Trump assassination attempt as in
before all these people hated you.
Before you could have blamed the quote
unquote starkers you
>> I'm not say you are being obtuse.
>> I'm saying
>> just said he does age play with some new
woman and FOR GOOD REASON ALLEGATIONS
BACK ON THE TABLE THAT this is just the
snarkers. He's the most hilarious gay
cope I've ever heard in my entire life.
By the way, do you want to go ahead and
reassert your evidence for how the cog?
Do you want to reassert your evidence
for how the cog is compromised? Because
we have two
snarkers in our Discord.
>> No, compromised because you run it.
>> Disavow.
>> Simple. Such a dis.
>> It's mindblowing.
>> Connor, I have never in my
>> I have never in my life said that every
swatting attempt or whatever has come
from the uh H3 whatever the the snarker
people. I don't actually 100% know that.
The very first time I got swatted was
after the
>> So why do they deserve the doxing?
>> I thought I thought esports Batman,
Wicked Supreme, JTO, uh Jtock, Queen,
and Doobie. I thought they all deserve
doxing because they were complicit in
your doxing, swatting, and harassment. I
thought that's why they deserve to be
doxed.
>> No, it's because they have engaged in a
year and a half. Keep going.
>> We could just watch your content for the
last 6 months and see you running away
from your own talking points.
How are How are you running away from
your own talking points right now?
>> These aren't my talking points that why
did esports Batman deserve to get doxed?
>> No, I'm going to answer the other
question that you asked me before you
try to railroad.
>> By the way, Connor knows this cuz he was
defending the original talking points
and then Desessie ran from them. Conor
knows that he got pressed in the
original talking points and how much
they've changed. some other question.
You said, "What is my issue with these
people?" And I've said it and I've
clarified it 50 billion times. Is that
for a year and a half, these people have
run a real life long-term harassment
campaign that has encapsulated multiple
channels, multiple Discords, and
multiple mediums like websites like Kiwi
Farms and Discord? And
>> has it been a year and a half since the
court case was announced or everything
else that the court case was announced?
>> Total destruction of my career and my
life. That's been my issue.
>> Yeah. Yeah. And they're stochcastically
responsible for your swatting and
doxing. Yeah,
>> Connor. I'm not a baby. I don't give a
if some cops show up to my house with
some gun.
>> By the way, like I understand the TDD
thing was a was a thing. We dropped it
like within by like April it was gone.
By March it was gone.
>> What I care about is if people are
getting harassed who are peripheral to
me in my life where people are
>> in fact I think I did a whole speech on
how we were going to move away from the
Destiny content in March
>> making them where these people are not
the worst. You remember yesterday about
[__] doxing. Swatting is annoying. I
do admit it and I do consider a kind of
attempted murder. But I can deal with
that. What I can't deal with is every
single person peripheral in my life
getting mind. I'm watching you. You're
mine right now. That stuff. Oh, he's
basically he's just saying again. He
just doesn't like to talk. He doesn't
like that we talk about him in a
negative way. That is what it is, right?
He's just admitting it full out now. Now
he's trying to do a little shift. Little
shift while I'm in the room with all the
sickopants. Guys, it's just about
actually these people talking about me
the whole time. That's what it's always
been about. was a lot worse to me
because I have no control over that. I
can't do anything to influence that
rifles again.
>> Do you think Jtock convinced me that you
engage with like insane behaviors that
puts you at incredible risk? Your
obsession with my has nothing to do with
anything that's happened over the past 2
years except for the fact you
that you were an unstable woman who is
still threatening at this moment and who
was married to your political opposition
who wants to you I just want to ask you
>> this is Brit by the way this is Brit
he's referring to this fair question who
who gave you this idea that this person
is like anything relevant to any of the
past year and a half of real life
harassment towards other people I know
of harassment does anybody on social
media of interviewing a court case of
reaching out to witnesses. Oh, she she's
a
>> mentally unstable woman that you are
>> Her name is First of all, I'm not
telling this person right now. Okay,
number one. Number two, she's Is that
who she is?
>> Sorry, what
>> is that? Is her name save a sexual
online? She's the one in Sister that
reached out to the victim of my [__]
But if
she holds I shouldn't care about your
life.
>> When you're doing something so reckless
and stupid, it runs the risk of you
getting murdered. I as your friend
shouldn't have criticism of you.
>> God, the amount of the amount of pivot
sweep that you've done, none of this has
anything to do with my court case. You
are desperately running because you know
you can't.
I said that you are
and you're dangerous to yourself.
>> Okay. All right. That's good. That has
basically nothing to do with any of the
problems that I've been experiencing for
the past two years. But unless I get
>> You don't think that you're in a court
case right now because you're in a
danger to yourself?
>> Who was the I was
recording videos with Pixie. I should
have done that six years ago.
>> Lauren, I should
>> I'm sorry. You're almost there. You're
almost at the point that's actually a
good point.
>> Yeah. Please articulate your and how it
resulted in a court case. Please do.
>> Is you just not liking people having
casual or doing me because I'm a sane
adult. I don't like that my idiot
millionaire friend who is wildly
intelligent, wildly successful in so
many domains of his life, thought that
it was smart to send homemade
to random people on the internet. That's
why I'm calling you. JTO didn't tell me
that didn't tell me that. Doobie didn't
tell me that. I thought that you were
myself and I've pulled you
>> for two years.
>> That makes sense.
>> And you're still
>> If a Jessical fan showed up at my house
and me because they were so upset over
the court case, would that be my fault?
>> Sorry. If who showed up and murdered
you?
>> Jessical fan showed up at my house and
me because they were so upset about my
behavior, would that be my fault?
>> How about we change it to the griper?
>> Can Can you ask Can you answer that
question? You
>> No, no. I'll answer your question. If
the Groper showed up and murdered you.
Yeah, that'd be your fault.
>> If one of fans showed up at my house and
he murdered me. Okay. Would that be my
>> I literally just said I didn't want this
guy like and destitute tonight. Which by
the way took some some meditation to get
to that point in my life, okay? Where I
didn't just want this guy like like
trust me, it's been a process cuz this
guy's been trying to ruin my life at a
lot of different points, okay? Way more
than ever I've ever tried to go after
him. And I've gotten to the point where
I'm like, you know what, he doesn't have
to he doesn't have to get totally
destroyed. And now he's like, OH THE
THESE PEOPLE WANT to kill me. But if if
the if the husband and murdered you,
would that be your fault?
>> No, it he should blame his wife for
that. She didn't say married with you.
She first reached out to me. What do you
want me to say?
>> Okay. You're you're literally like
and it destroys your career.
>> No, that's not the main point. You The
main point is there's been a 2-year mass
harassment campaign that like you I
guess cuz I'm not going to be personal.
Okay, listen. Whatever problems or
issues that you have going on right now,
the fact that you are willing to sweep
every that these lun
>> Connor Connor you're mentally ill.
Connor, you're mentally ill. Connor,
you're like having a crash. You're
mentally ill. Conorics are doing online
because you don't like the way that I
have casual is the most insanely petty
watch I've ever heard in my entire life.
It's crazy to me.
>> Destiny, I'm not the person being sued
for $15 million for being a
person who is getting videos from a
griper and his wife. You psycho.
>> Is that why I'm being sued?
>> No, but that's why you're going to get
murdered. Isn't it? What? Where? Didn't
we have a theory that Rose and the Rose
was like um A Solo was a gor and Rose
was like that was the early theory,
right? That's what Destiny
>> [__] Is that why is that why I'm being
sued?
>> You're being sued for being 100%.
>> Okay. So, just help me draw the line.
So, no more recording videos or no more
having casual at all
>> with adult women who insane.
>> Why are you saying adult women? Set your
PARAMETERS TO 25 TO 40 and have with
people that you have A CONVERSATION WITH
FOR MORE THAN 30 SECONDS. It's so
normal. It's so normal. as many people
as you want, but stop banging people who
are crazy.
>> Okay, you want a lot of you talking
about a lot of conversations with who's
pretty close to my age who's probably
more probably Lauren Luna, but great
advice. Thank you. Thank you. I'm sorry.
The [__] does Launa have to do with you?
Another [__] that you crazy who's
trying to ruin your life. As a matter
fact, hold on. That's a great point.
Destiny, there's another that you that's
trying to ruin your goddamn life. Thank
you for bringing it up. I forgot about
Lauren de Laguna. True.
>> You know what happened today? Pilate
text me today. Hila text me today and
she said, "Oh man, Steven's going crazy.
You know, this kind of reminds me of uh
back what happened with Lauren." And you
know what I had the same response? WHICH
LAUREN?
DUDE, WHAT? Oh my god.
That's a crazy
Dude, that's amazing. That's amazing.
>> You know why? Because you've had with
two or three of them and one of them's
crazy and trying to ruin your life
because you're it's an amazing mistake.
>> There one everywhere, you know.
>> So,
>> dude, if you could have Chen, you would
too.
>> This could have been okay. Excuse me.
Pretty hot. Okay. Number one. Number
two. If the whole thing is you hate me
having say that and then you can tell
all the [__] I love you and I want
you to stop.
>> [__] Oh my god. It's such a cringe
thing to say shut the [__] up. Okay. You
love me after every conversation. Did
you not mean it?
>> I think that me saying I love you after
conversation is a lot more casual than
whatever weird you are right now. Okay.
>> Oh yeah. Everybody, Dude, we all know
the entire world knows yours. Hold on.
Hold on. That actually reminds me, guys.
Hold on. That That reminds me of
like, oh yeah, it reminds me of when he
crashed out of Lauren and Connor's
response. Do you have any idea how
little that narrows it down?
>> Look at THE DOXING HISTORY. WHAT DID
ESPORTS Batman do to deserve to be
docked?
>> People like you obsess over it. Esports
Batman cheered on as a Discord server,
gave legal advice to a Discord server
that was that was harassing a
trafficking victim, encouraging her to
jo. They thought it'd be an epic own
that
>> they didn't know she was a sex
trafficking victim. Like they they
didn't know this, but that came from the
deposition.
>> Fantastic.
When did he
>> That's Did he dox you?
>> No.
>> Did he stalk you?
>> I would consider that stalking. Yes.
>> Oh, okay. Uh, did he swap you?
>> You notice how Connor doesn't respond to
what I because it's a insane statement
when this guy reached out like from a
good place at first. Right. Well, I
think I think he had good intentions in
his heart the whole time and I think the
the record will exonerate Saiba. That is
my sus that is my suspicion. I've not
seen the whole record yet, but I suspect
it will cuz Destiny's lied so much about
every other aspect.
>> Check
because people talking about you on the
internet is not a good reason to dox
them. Hold on. I just want to hear you
say this. I just want to hear you say
this to be clear. People reaching out to
the victim of a sex trafficking crime in
order to harass her and her family to
force her to draw my case. That's just
people talking. CONNOR,
>> NO. CYBER could be the one person where
if you doxed him, I'd be like, but
esports Batman isn't Caiba, is he?
>> Do you think that Caiba exists without a
whole Discord server cheering him the
on?
>> Okay. Yeah. I I I love this. So, so
since I'm a snarker now and since I
enjoy I'm just mind driven by the
snarkers now I sing Jtock and doing with
them about everything. I should cfka
because he enables the infinite machine
based off of your logic.
>> Do you think that
>> he's fair game? He talks to you. He's a
lawyer. He gives you legal feedback. I
should rap him.
>> I should [__] Sure. Show me. Show me
Kfka engaging in the behavior that was
anywhere near what esports Batman does.
You know what? No. It really It really
boils down to this.
>> Oh my god.
>> It really boils down to this. If you're
going to people, have a good reason and
evidence it. You haven't done that. And
if you're going to have with people,
stop having with crazy people who are
going to ruin your
>> I'll just repeat that over and over and
over again. I don't want to litigate
every detail with you because I don't
give a because what I'm saying right now
is so true. Here's the other thing.
Here's the other thing out. You're like,
"Oh, Conor's obsessed with me."
>> You know what? Dan and Mutton are
because they would never say this to
your face in life. No, they would.
Except they do in real life. They don't
have to do a show on the
>> They do. Then why don't you listen to
him? You stupid. Every single one of
your friends is consistently telling you
that you are so that you are ruining
your life and yet you are coming to me
and saying, "Connor, you're
>> Does Dan know about Brit? Does Dan know
about the age play DMs with the Groper
and sorry, the Groper's wife? The the
psycho groper's wife. Does Dan know
about this
>> squatching?
>> Has Dan been sweeping for this?
>> You're obsessing with me. Hold on. If
I'm obsessed with you, why are Dan
saying the same thing? Is he obsessed
with you? Is Moon is Kyla? Is Lauren
>> with me?
>> How many friends do you have left? By
the WAY, AT WHAT POINT DO YOU GO, "OH,
it's me."
>> How many wives you have left, Connor?
What the Bro, are you
>> What the hell? What the hell?
>> I was married FOR 15 YEARS AND I WAS
LOYAL to one woman for 15 years. BUT
HOLD ON. LET'S POINT OUT. That's the
closest I've seen to like the old
destiny right there. The the quickness
of the comeback. That's the closest I've
seen to like a spark of any life in this
guy in like 5 months.
>> How stupid what YOU JUST SAID WAS. HOW
MANY WIVES DO YOU HAVE LEFT, CONOR? HAD
ONE. AND I was married to her for 15
years. And I was loyal to her for 15
years. You
>> idiot.
>> Oh my god. Keep going. Are you good?
>> No, I'm good. Yeah, you're a idiot. You
think one 15-year relationship compares
to your entire life of social
dysfunction? That's so I don't even know
why you would say it,
>> Connor. Weren't we standing outside your
house when you were asking me? I should
live a life like you now. I should go
and have all this fun NOW THAT I'M
[__]
>> YEAH. AND YOU KNOW WHAT HAPPENED? I GOT
TINDER. I DID ONE HOOKUP. I was like,
"This is gay and cringe. I'm going to go
find a serious girlfriend." And then I
got a serious girlfriend because I'm
almost 30.
How are you, Conor? I guess you're just
not very
a personal problem. Don't take it out on
me.
>> Grow up. You're 40.
>> Grow up, Connor. You are on the internet
talking about
>> You are age playing with a griper's
wife.
>> You are age plane with a groper. Can we
get details wife? And I details our age
plane with detailers or details. Now
>> grow up.
>> Respectfully, you have no idea what
you're talking about. Okay.
>> No, I do.
>> I know.
>> I got the logs
>> from him and from her.
>> Okay. I don't The thing is I don't want
to out their business on the internet.
Okay. But you don't know what you're
talking about. I promise you. Okay.
Number one. Number two.
>> I have screenshots. I know what I'm
talking about. SO, HOW ABOUT YOU JUST
GO, "DAMN, CONOR, you're right. I
shouldn't be accepting videos from a
griper and his wife who wants to murder
me. I need to chill the out."
>> You said you have screenshots. Who sent
you the screenshots?
>> Are we
>> I'm not sending you the screenshots of
the graer who wants to murder Destiny.
But trust me, I have them. And the
reason why he can't deny it is because
he knows it's true. It's because you
have a fraction of the story that is
absolutely not worth. What could you
possibly tell me that is going to tell
that's going to be like, "Oh, Destiny
was right. He should have the groper and
his wife."
>> OH MY GOD, this is brilliant. What
information or context could you
possibly share with me that would change
my opinion on this?
>> I am not going to out parts of any
conversation like this that I have with
another person or people. You're insane.
>> Dude, his voice is getting so high
pitched. He is so pressed right now. I'm
not even going to a convert to even ask.
No, I'm not. I see my friend who's a
idiot up and I've tried to be nice about
it and that's not working. So, I'm going
to be mean about it. You're
don't know how to manage your
relationships. Anytime anybody
challenges you on anything, even if they
love you, you run away because you're
afraid of growing up. You are not 13
anymore. You are
>> what locks somebody in at a young age?
What is like a thing that happens at a
young age?
>> 40. Grow up. Keep going. We have to keep
going.
>> Every piece is in place. The infinity
stones.
>> That was rude. That was rude. I'll give
you one more. You know wanted to get
back with you.
>> Really?
>> That was rude.
>> Yes. She loves you. She wants the best
for you. She thinks that underneath all
the sludge and of your up little life,
there is something redeeming about you.
And I agree with her. BUT YOU ARE SUCH a
that it is impossible to be your friend.
It's impossible to be your partner. It
is impossible to tell you that you're
wrong. It's impossible for you to take a
L.
I'm sorry. That's awesome. That was
awesome. Okay. But also, am I the only
one who can tell that Connor's had this
argument in the shower like a hundred
times before this moment? That like this
is borderline scripted from how many
times he's run this argument in his head
at this point? Am I the only I feel like
I can't be the only one.
>> Just take a L and take a goddamn lap.
Connor, if you want to L. Me and Lauren
have been dating for like 3 months and
we both agreed not to tell you because
you asked her out while we were in the
middle of dating. You have no IDEA WHAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT WITH LITERALLY
ANYTHING YOU'RE SAYING.
>> YES, I DO. And you were too much of a TO
COMMIT. YOU WERE TOO MUCH OF A TO
COMMIT. OH, NO. THIS HOT INTERNET
POLITICS WHO I DESTROYED MY LIFE FOR IN
2022. OH, SHE LOVES ME. I NEED TO GO
BPD.
You're a idiot. You're an idiot. You you
literally had Lauren back and you
ditched her for BPD girls because you're
you are
you don't know anything about my life.
You don't know anything about my
personal life.
>> YES, I DO ANYTHING ABOUT THE OTHER LIFE.
>> DO DO YOU WANT ME TO GET THE SCREENSHOTS
THAT I GOT FROM LAUREN SOUTHERN?
>> You are self-destructing right now
because I I think you should
>> He's not self-destructing.
>> Take one week off. But that's my
suggestion. I'm not going to be here and
contribute to you. Literally,
>> you should take a whole year off. DO YOU
KNOW HERE? HERE'S another thing. Here's
another thing.
>> All right, he's gone. I'll go ahead and
share with the people who are watching.
>> He did mushrooms that said that he was
alone inside his room and he ignored
that. But exactly what the is happening
is he can't take criticism. He can't let
people love him. He can't let anybody
get close. And he would rather cycle
through a roster of BBD e and slowly
destroy his life rather than get his
[__] together and grow the up. And I'm
sick of it. I played nice with it. I'm
not playing nice with it anymore. I'm
>> understand. Please, please, please. But
do you think now is the time to litigate
his life? He's literally under attack.
It is not. You're watching a man and
he's trying,
you want to sit here with you want to
sit here with a straight face and you
want to tell me that he should be a
groper and his wife while he's ongoing
litigation for for leaking homemade.
>> That's the appropriate time to with BPD
girls. You're you're really angry and I
get it and and I'm not saying you don't
have any reason not to be angry to be
angry, right? But like this is not the
time. This is not the place.
>> Yes, it is.
>> It's exactly the time and the place.
>> You know why? Because it's been years.
It's been years. No one will stand up to
this and tell him to his face that he's
being a And you know what? I don't give
a He knows that I'm right. He's he
destroys career opportunities for his
own nihilist hedenism. He could improve
his relationships, but he won't. He has
opportunities for deeper relationships
and he runs away from them. [__] that.
This is the exact time to litigate it.
And by the way, here's another detail.
Hanging out with A WHY IS HIS NUMBER one
defender a
>> His kid is getting doxed and you're the
one blaming him for hedonism? That is
ridiculous.
>> You're a Why would I talk to you?
>> Conor's with disconnect. There you go.
There you go. He's out. He's out. He's
out. He's out. He's out. He's out. Let's
go. What a time to BE ALIVE. WHAT A TIME
to be alive the entire time.
>> Could you imagine? Could you imagine? Oh
my god. Could you imagine? I could
imagine it. Conor is terrible with tech.
>> Was I muted the entire time?
>> That's a crazy question to ask after
you've done everything.
>> Destiny ran. You think I need to sit
around and talk to a I'm not talking to
a If you want to talk to a You go over
there. You go talk to the
>> I'm not talking to the I'm not the only
one who feels this way. Do you
understand? I'm not the only one that
feels this way. Kylo feels this way. Dan
probably feels this way. Mutton probably
feels this way. Lauren de Laguna back in
the day probably felt this way. They all
feel this way. Destiny is intelligent.
He's charismatic. He's funny. He can be
generous. He can be gracious. He can be
kind. There is a soul underneath all of
the [__]
But he cannot get over his own trauma.
He can't get out of his own way. and he
wants to BPD
into the sunset and slowly but surely
ruin his life. I've tried to be nice.
I've tried to be polite. I've tried to
be calm. I've tried everything. I've
needed to say that for a year. I've
needed to say that for a year.
>> Conor's been h Connor's had some demons.
Okay, Connor
Connor has some demons going on typing.
Not to me.
>> And you know what? I'll say this.
>> I checked. It's not to me. BPD girl. Her
message to me is, "Oh my god, please
stop. He's never going to talk to me
again."
>> I just I I truly like despise the whole
like um stigmatization thing.
>> It just it it just feels so annoying now
that I see it.
like this is I know Connor I know Connor
wants like to get through to Destiny and
I know it might seem like it's nothing
but this whole thing of the the BPD
e-girl thing this is only this is a
device used to make it seem like they're
not human and they're not important so
they can forgive Destiny right that they
it doesn't matter anyway
>> Stephen casually engages with mentally
ill women
>> or we way behind on kick
>> you're pretty crazy
>> huge wick tweet oh my holy I way behind.
Hold on.
>> Oh my my chat's way. Hold on.
>> I don't want to talk. What? Why? Why
would I want to talk to you right now?
>> Huge wick tweet. Why are they doing this
public? This is a huge [__] that
>> was not time to scold
>> sex
up YouTube and politics. He that he hung
out with that Nazi. He hung out with
that Nazi because he wanted a crumb of
Nazi and then he took it to uh the
America events. He was bringing side to
America events. You you losers.
>> Oh, he's unchained.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I'm a pathetic grown
man. Why? Because I won't let my friend
endlessly run his goddamn into a uh a
broom over and over again. And I won't
let him jump onto brakes in front of me
over and over and over and over again.
Off.
[__] off. Oh, you
>> did you try to southern? What a friend.
No, I was single. I just got divorced. I
like Lauren. I said, "Hey, are you guys
dating? I might ask her out." And he
said, "No." And then I just talked to
her as a friend. And then I never asked
her out. Watch. Y'all are so
Y'all are so
Y'all are so This man is being sued for
$15
million.
No, he's not not being sued for $15
million, but whatever. He has spent
$800,000
>> because of what he's done with his
and you're saying who cares?
You guys are
You guys You guys are literally the
dumbest
the dumbest
on the internet.
Steven's lost $800,000. Is that not a
big deal? Stephven's up his
relationships with political people. Is
that not a big deal? Steven's lost
mainstream opportunities.
Is that not a big deal? Y'all are bad
friends.
>> I need the guys. The three guys are all
of y'all. All of y'all who are in here
are like pocket watching, watching. Why
do you care? You are horrible.
>> So badly, man.
>> You are horrible human beings. You're
And I'm going to be so happy when you
get bored and leave my stream.
All you
sniveling worms. All you worms in my
chat. All you vile,
spineless,
toothless,
virtuous, sacks of [__] in my chat right
now who would let Destiny do whatever
the he wanted to do as long as it
entertained you.
>> Hold on. Apparently we apparently
Destined.
Can I just say like a quick thing? And
like I know it's all a meme in a game to
everybody, okay? But like it is insane
how sociopathic this group of people is
to weaponize people that are either
having extremely crazy personal life
stuff going on, which I don't hold
against Connor at all. And listen, we
said a lot of mean things in here, but I
imagine that
>> Conor's mentally ill. Conor's mentally
ill. Conor's mentally ill. Conor's
mentally ill.
>> Conor has a bunch of [__] going on in
his life. Okay.
>> Oh, he's sweeping right now because he
feels bad. cuz he feels like he's like
losing a number one defender.
>> I I just I just want to say real quick
um from my perspective at the very least
the doxing isn't even the same. Like for
example, when Destiny doxes, it's like a
face dox or it's like um
>> it's a face do. Yeah.
>> Post
um does happen. But the thing is is that
like when orbiters from horrendous by
the way doxed people it's their email
it's their address it's like everything
like the doxing
>> unless they're like doing like real life
harm which I don't think SA was doing by
talking are broken on doxing doxing in
itself like doesn't matter the the thing
is what people do with the docs is why
people don't want to be doxed right
doesn't matter it's the fact
>> this is not this is not like I chill
>> people who are fighting with people to
do, you know, whatever it is you're
worried about. So, on their side, and I
know that Doobie, I think, has run
around saying this, and I think he even
said it to Wick, he might have said it
to Connor. People say these things like,
"Yeah, the DJs are harassing us all the
time." Who? What harassment? Nobody has
done literally anything. Nothing has
happened to any of these people and
they're acting like, you know, them
having a name posted is literally the
end of the world. Like meanwhile, yeah.
I mean, obviously on my side, like not
even just me, but like I've shown DMs of
like real life friends I've had that
have gotten harassed on Instagram and
had their employers contacted and [__]
Like the idea that it's just not even
remotely the same. I don't know where
they get this idea from.
>> I tried to ask him where he was getting
the information from and he misheard me
and it was really cringe. But yeah,
>> by the way, Dusty's posted what he
thought was like my dad's obituary to
mock the person's death. I don't know.
Like he's definitely posted a lot of
crazy details that are just like wild.
Going to go back to Connor for a second.
Watch more Connor. Connor done.
>> I'm done.
>> Well, I think you mean with Destiny, not
the stream. Thank you for answering, but
I think you mean with Destiny, not the
stream.
>> I'm not sweeping for it. I'm not
covering it up. I'm not sweeping for it.
You Conor, you're projecting. You did.
Bye. You yelled at your friend and
didn't even listen to him. You know why?
You know why?
>> My friend
someone Oh, excuse me. Shot homemade
with a girl. Shot homemade with dozens
of people. Met somebody on the internet
for two weeks and sent them all the
homemade and sent them the DMs
of him and a woman he loved 10 days.
That's He got sued for $15 million.
He's down 800,000 in never got sued for
$50 million. Just to be clear, the offer
was over 150K. It's probably why you
said 175 because you know this court
case
>> points actually.
>> And while he was in the middle of a
mastrom in which everybody hated his
guts, he thought the best thing to do
was to the wife of a griper. A griper
who went on to want to and join a
telegram group saying that uh
>> why why that why did he want to do that?
And then he has
>> to come to me to my face and to say I
know it's Doobie. I know it's the
Snarkers. I know it's Jtock. I know it's
Queen. And they deserve to be doxed and
harassed. They deserve to get kicked off
the internet. No, you don't. You don't
know that. Show me the evidence. You
don't know that. You don't know that.
You all you in my chat who would just
let him do whatever the [__] He's still
going hard. You're Yeah. You think I did
that for money? You too.
You know what would be so much easier?
You know, it would be so much easier to
stay in orbit. It would be so much
easier to be food shops. Do you
understand that? I could just be
Destiny's loyal little soldier. I could
just say, "Oh, Destiny, what are the
talking points today, master? Let me
regurgitate them. Let me reinforce them.
Let me not think about them critically
at all. I could be food shops. I could
be a successful food shops."
Food shops.
>> Yeah.
>> Don't come at me with that happy
worship.
worship. Destiny is not that he was like
and liked that he is a progressive. If
he doesn't consider you a friend, you
don't have to sweep anymore. Okay, well,
I'm not. There you go. I wasn't
sweeping.
>> Are you sure you're not sweeping, Conor?
>> I haven't swept in the past 6 hours.
>> I feel like Connor would never go all
the way into like actually hurting
Destiny. I feel like there's got to be
more.
>> They spent years calling you a Okay,
what the [__] does that have to do with
anything? Conor, is it true that he's
been getting swatted since before the
Grier situation? Who gives a the point
is that he doesn't know that it's the
snark
>> been getting swatted since before the
Jtock situation too.
>> But he wants everybody to go along with
the narrative that it is the snarkers so
he can the snarkers. That's the point.
You could have listened Conor even if
he's 100% in the wrong yelling over
someone you're trying to help isn't
productive. Well, I've already listened
for enough. I've already listened for
long enough. It's his turn to listen. I
don't think anybody's more of a quatcher
than Jaketock, but you'd be close. All
right. Here's a 24-hour because I like
you tribe. Go eat a dick. Can you
justify the gripper wanting to kill him?
What kind of friend thinks that way? Oh,
I'm sorry. Somebody your wife, what do
you think the chances are that you're
going to kill them? Is it zero? Cuz
you're a off. Got to start from the
start, but when you stated uh wanted to
say you're awesome, real talk most so
far. Thanks. Do you think that is okay?
I don't give a wick. I don't give a
flying I don't give a flying about
people calling you a pedo right now. Can
you let me deal with a thousand losers
in my chat?
>> It's definitely not a
>> just talks like one
>> who want who think Destiny can't do
anything. That's a completely snark
talking point and telling of events. You
can ask them what really happened and
not believe people who make stuff and
harass them. Shut the [__] up, you
loser. I need I I need You don't think
that I myself think that Destiny is a
Here's 24 hours.
>> Enjoy it. This is going to cost us money
because we are no longer friends with
Destiny. Who cares? Who cares?
>> Yeah, Connor just bought some new fans.
Got some new fans after this. This is
crazy.
>> Plenty. Here's 24 hours. Thank you for
not giving the literal platform. You're
welcome. You're welcome. Moon
Jeb Tan says, "Sorry to see it all go
down like this. I've heard you and Kyler
try to give them the benefit of the
doubt for so many years and he'll act
like you're suddenly a snarker
overnight. Yep.
Any of y'all feel like this is the bad
timeline? Ever since they shot her on,
babe, brother's probably been getting
swatted since 2015, but exactly what
Conor just said. The heavy imping, etc.
Masterminds. Yep. Biggest bump to your
viewership. I don't know. On Friday, I
had a thousand. Where are we at today?
What was the peak today? I think he's
more upset about the people outside of
himself getting docks and harassed.
Yeah. You think so? Yeah. You think
Destiny has empathy? Shut the up.
>> He doesn't. He He does not at all.
>> He's a sociopath. Get the [__] out of
here.